If you asked most of your friends which was
faster.
The fastest production car in the world or
the fastest helicopter, I think most of them
would guess the helicopter.
Intuitively we expect anything flying in the
air to have a higher top speed than anything
on the ground could achieve, but physics is
a cruel mistress and conventional helicopters
are doomed to a max speed of just 400 km/h,
with that record being set over 30 years ago
by John Trevor Egginton in a Westland Lynx,
while just this year the Koenigsegg Agera
RS demolished that record driving at 445 km/h,
and sure you don’t have to worry about traffic
in your helicopter or those pesky speed suggestions
on the road, but the bragging rights for top
speed will always go to cars for the rest
of time.
So how can this be, what quirks of physics
are limiting helicopters from flying faster?
First let’s look at what limits a cars top
speed.
To determine top speed, we first need to identify
the forces attempting to slow the vehicle
down.
In space, with no resistance, even a small
force can continually accelerate an object
until it reaches close to the speed of light,
if it is maintained for long enough, which
would require a silly amount of energy.
On earth though, every time we provide energy
to our vehicle, resistance in the form of
air resistance and rolling resistance in the
wheels are sapping it away.
Eventually we get to a point where the energy
we are providing the vehicle equals the energy
being taken away, and the vehicle cannot travel
any faster.
In the case of cars the top speed is predominantly
determined by air resistance, for now we will
ignore rolling resistance as it’s negligible
in comparison.
The equation for drag force is given by this
equation, and the equation for power is simply
force times velocity.
Rearranging these variables we get an equation
for top speed.
Applying this to the Agera RS specs, we find
it’s top speed almost perfectly with a decent
degree of accuracy, considering we ignored
rolling resistance.
Decreasing our drag coefficient and frontal
area also increases top speed, but to increase
power we need to increase airflow to cool
the engine, so this is a difficult balancing
act.
We also discovered in a previous video that
designing rubber tires capable of withstanding
these rotational speeds is an incredibly difficult
task, with the Bloodhound SSC opting for aluminium
wheels to break the land speed record.
These are the limiting factors for a car,
so what are the limiting factors for a helicopter.
Helicopters have to deal with all the same
problems as cars in counteracting aerodynamic
drag, but first a helicopter needs to overcome
the force of gravity, using the same rotor
that will need to provide forward thrust.
So is this just an issue of needing engine
power?
Partially yes,
The Westland Lynx was powered by not one but
two Rolls-Royce Gem turboshaft engines, each
equaling the power of a single Agera RS twin-turbo
V8 engine.
Yet, even with twice the power, it still can’t
beat it in a straight line race.
How can this be?
Let’s go on a journey as the helicopter
takes off and transitions to forward flight,
and see why it can’t go any faster even
with stronger material for blades or more
powerful engines.
As the Lynx powers up the blades begin to
rotate faster, providing more lift according
to this equation.
Where A is the swept area of the blades, Cl
is the coefficient of lift of the blades and
v is the velocity of the blades.
The coefficient of lift depends on a lot of
things, like the geometry of the blades and
angle of attack, but for the sake of simplicity
we will assume it is constant.
Once the lift is greater than the weight of
the helicopter it begins to rise, and when
it equals the weight the helicopter will enter
a hover state.
Now to go forward, the pilot will need to
transition some of the lift to thrust by angling
the rotor disk forward.
But here we meet our first problem.
Looking downwards, we can see that left-side
of our blade is moving backwards relative
to the the direction of travel, and our right
hand side to moving forward relative to the
direction of travel.
Similar to planes, the aerodynamic surface
of the blade will generate more or less lift
depending how quickly it is moving through
the air.
So our right side generates more lift that
our left.
To counteract this the rotor integrates an
ingenious little mechanism, where the blade
can change its angle of attack as it rotates.
Here the advancing blade will have a lower
its angle of attack, thereby lowering it’s
lift, and the retreating blade will increase
it’s angle of attack, increasing it’s
lift.
This helps equalise the lift across the rotor
disk, but this solution has it’s limit.
As we increase an aerofoils angle of attack
the lift increases, but eventually he hit
a point of where flow separation occurs and
the aerofoil begins to generate less lift.
This is our first speed limit.
The helicopter will eventually hit a speed
where it cannot adjust the angle attack any
further to compensate to dissymmetry of lift.
However there are solutions to this problem.
If we have two blades rotating in opposite
directions, we no longer have to compensate
for this dissymmetry in lift, as the two blades
will have the opposite dissymmetry of lift
and cancel each other out.
This is what allows the Chinook to cruise
along faster than any other military helicopter
at 315 km/h.
Now we have overcome one speed limit, but
even now the Agera RS is still speeding ahead
.
The next speed limit we reach is the sound
barrier, if we continue to increase forward
velocity, the tips of the advancing blade
will eventually break the sound barrier.
And while planes can handle breaking through
the sound barrier with the correct design,
they don’t need to pass through it several
hundreds of times a minute.
This adds to the problems of dissymmetry of
lift, but also causes problems with varying
stress that fatigue the material of the blades
and ultimately lead to failure.
This speed limit poses a more difficult challenge
to overcome in our current configuration.
To travel faster, we need to increase thrust,
to increase thrust we need to increase lift.
Let’s take a look at the equation from before
to see how we can do that.
We can either increase our rotor speed, or
we can increase our blade diameter.
Increasing the blade velocity will obviously
make us more likely to break the sound barrier,
but so will increasing our blade diameter,
as the velocity of the blade increases as
we travel down the blade.
Designers have hit an optimum balance between
these two variable already, so that’s not
an option for increasing speed.
So how else can we increase helicopter speed?
By converting more of that vertical lift to
horizontal thrust, but this poses a new problem,
at some point were are going to hit a point
where the helicopter is not generating enough
lift to keep itself aloft.
The solutions to this problem are hitting
a point where the we can scarcely call the
aircraft a helicopter.
Enter the Eurocopter X cubed, which holds
the unofficial helicopter speed record, unofficial
exactly because it is not strictly a helicopter,
as it generates a large portion of it’s
forward thrust from vertical propellers.
This decreases the burden of the horizontal
rotor to generate forward thrust allowing
it slow its rotational speed, minimising the
impact of our previous speed limits, the rotor
can also decrease it’s rotational velocity
as the helicopter gains speed as more lift
is generated from two small wings on either
side of the helicopter.
These design choices allowed the x cubed to
reach top speed of 472 km/h, beating the previous
record held by the Sikorsky X2, and demolishing
anything ever achieved by a production car.
Pushing this design ideology even further
we completely blur the lines of what a helicopter
is, with tiltrotors, like the Osprey.
This aircraft has a top speed of 565 km/h,
this combined with it’s incredible vertical
take-off capabilities, that are not hindered
by limited weight issues like jet engine powered
aircraft like the Harrier, has made it an
incredibly versatile tool for the US military.
Another incredibly versatile tool that could
give you some additional lift, is Skillshare,
all the animations and illustrations you saw
in todays episode were created by me, but
just 3 years ago I knew nothing about animation.
I taught myself the basics during one Chinese
New Years holiday when I was living in Malaysia.
1 week later I knew enough to start experimenting
with animation styles and figure out how I
wanted to this channel to look.
A year later again I uploaded my first video
to YouTube and it went viral straight away.
Learning new skills gives you opportunities
in life.
This is why I love working with Skillshare,
you can learn from thousands of courses in
design, business, technology and loads more.
I learned loads about animation from watching
a course from my friends at In A Nutshell.
I guarantee you, you will find one course
that you will want to learn if you follow
this link and it will get the first 1000 people
a 2 month membership for just 99 cent.
So ask yourself right now.
What skill have you been putting off learning.
What project have you been dreaming of completing,
but you aren’t sure if you have the skills
to do it.
Why not start right now and sign up to Skillshare
using the link below.
You have nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain.
As usual, thanks for watching and thank you
to my incredible Patreon supporters.
I just opened a Discord server for my Patreon
supporters where we can chat and share ideas
for videos.
The links to my twitter, instagram and facebook
pages are below too.